Frankie.
Mila is a comic book artist,
writer Ans movie director who is known for his edge.
He storytelling.
He one very few creators who has worked on major projects both for marvel and DC
comics.
Some of his most popular works are dare devil,
Sin City 300 and Batman the dark night.
While you may have seen his name on the cover of a comic book or in the movie
credits,
few people know the story of how Frank Miller went from being a comic book fan
growing up in a small town in Vermont.
Just someone who has gained international fame and fortune and in the
biographics video today.
Well,
we're going to tell you all about him.
Okay.
Frank Miller was born in Olney,
Maryland on January the 27th 1957 into a large Irish Catholic family.
His mother was a nurse and just father ran his own business as an electrician
and carpenter,
Frank's family moved to Montpellier,
Vermont where he grew up with his six siblings when he was six years old.
Frank Miller bought his first a Batman Comic Book and after reading the comics
so much so they began drawing Batman on pieces of scrap paper.
He took some of his parents' typewriter papers so the d could fold and staple
the pages together into a small comic book.
He then drew his first comic and presented it to his mother saying that this was
what he was going to do when he grew up,
his father became a traveling salesman and he would drive back and forth between
Vermont and New York City.
Frankie would go with him on these road trips just so he could look through the
big comic book stores in New York and by all of the different titles that he
could engage in a small town if a month for the rest of his young life.
He would read comics and practice drawing in the hopes that he could make his
dreams come true.
Growing up his favorite movies to watch where film noir movies like a touch of
evil and Chinatown.
These stories,
they always had a lot of action with corrupt detectives and beautiful famine for
towels.
He especially loved the movies that were in black and white because of the drama
that fell,
make,
were able to achieve with all of the dark shadows on the screen over the years.
He read every comic he could get his hands on.
It wasn't just enjoying the stories as a fan.
He was analyzing both the writing and as the artwork absorbing every little
detail he would read.
Every new character published by marvel comics,
including one called of a cat claws of the cats,
which premiered in November of 1972 when he was 16 years old.
He wrote a fan letter to marvel comics.
Soon after reading this new comic,
this letter was published in issue number three.
In the letter he wrote wonderful at last,
a woman character with character.
I for 1:00 AM sick of the helpless female types,
which of cluttered up comics for so long.
This woman that Frank Miller was talking about,
which ends up being renamed tiger and what many people have not heard of the
superhero today.
She would be an inspiration for how he portrayed his female characters in the
future.
Even though they'd only responded to his fan lesser.
It was still exhilarating to see his name in print still.
He always knew he wanted to draw comics for the rest of his life and he felt
ready to leave his parents home.
On one of these long road trips with father,
he packed a few extra bags with the intention of moving to New York City when he
was only 17 all his life.
Frank Miller dreams of permanently getting out of the countryside and he was
exhilarated to be surrounded by the city that he was so in love with.
One of the first things that he did was visit the empire state building.
At the time,
there were no screens up to prevent people from pulling over the ledge if they
went to the very top.
Therefore,
Miller was able to sit up on the ledge with a sketch book and he was drawing the
skyline.
He kept on sitting on rooftops to get a sense of the city from those angles.
These drawings would eventually ends up in his later comics.
Miller lived in a tiny studio apartments and he was able to use the carpentry
skills.
It learns by working at his father's business to find gigs that would help him
pay his rent.
The apartment was very small and old and there were cockroaches and water bugs
crawling all over the place.
He was motivated to work for a better life and to try and start his career.
Therefore,
he started making appointments since taking his drawing portfolio to various
comic book publishers around New York.
He matched with Joe Orlando at DC comics.
You've told Miller this,
he was not good enough to work for them and he might have a B.
His portfolio was held together with strings and bugs that crawl inside it at
some point.
As we were talking,
one of these past screwed out of my portfolio into my lap and so I could do
nothing but compromise or friends during the interview as it squirmed and
desperately fought for its life.
It was not the brightest day of my life.
Needless to say,
he did not get to that job.
That level of constant humiliation.
It would have been enough for some people to pack that bags and move back home
and for awhile it fruity did seem as if Mila's dream would never become a
reality,
but he never gave up with every rejection he kept trying to improve and see.
Went to more and more interviews.
Frank Miller's favorite artist by far was Neal Adams,
who's Batman and green lands and comics that made him a big superstar.
Hey,
the background's in advertising,
so his pictures at an elements of photo realism with accurate and [inaudible].
He was looking for more of Adams as work and trying to aspire to be like him.
When you went on an interview at marvel comics,
he actually got to meet and Neil Adams and he blessed him,
know how much he admired his work.
Adam's credits his daughter with his decision to give her a chance.
He stated,
obviously she felt sorry for him because he was a skinny kid who looks like a to
crane.
He went on to say that middle of the portfolio was awful.
It was so bad.
My heart sunk and I was like,
oh my God.
One of these guys,
even though he harshly criticized his work,
so he graciously calls up one of his friends to help Frank Mir.
I get a job as a storyboard artist,
as an advertising firm.
The artwork that was required for these kind of jobs did not need to be as
realistic as a marvel comic.
Birkins this way,
Miller was able to get professional experience and get tips from coworkers on a
daily basis.
Now,
the Frank Miller was a working artist.
He no longer had to struggle to find carpentry work to pay the bills.
He was drawing for a living and he was getting better during the process,
but he still wants it to do comics.
Every time.
Miller thought that maybe it improved aunt and off he would go to Neil Adams and
apply to work at marvel again.
It took a very long time to truly understand how to improve.
Adams would take middle drawings and place a piece of tracing paper over the top
so that he could draw his own version,
showing how to properly redraw the same image.
He then pushed the copy paper towards Miller as if to say,
try again.
Often watching Neil Adams so many times he began to study anatomy textbooks to
get a good feeling for drawing the human body.
You realize that his biggest problem was creating accurate proportions and
understanding how muscles and bones move together.
It would practice these tips that Adams gave him and came back again and again.
Finally,
one day Neal Adams looked at the drawings and picks up the phone and call one of
his connections and to get him a job with gold key comics.
Adam said,
whatever you do,
don't say that.
I'm responsible for Frank Miller.
I've done the same thing for a hundred guys and nobody responded the way.
Frank did.
Nobody advanced that quickly and I made it hard for him.
If you're already gone through it,
you'd have gone home crying.
They were publishing the comic book version of the twilight zone.
There were very few copies made because it wasn't an incredibly popular comic,
but Frank Miller,
we're still over the moon because this was his chance to get his foot in the
door of the industry.
He was so nervous about doing a good job with his first paid gig.
Did it took him three weeks to complete just three pages,
but this was just the beginning of his career as a comic book artist.
After this,
he started getting small gigs at both DC and marvel and to truly begun his
journey to success.
As time went on,
Frank Miller had enough professional experience under his belt to be hired as a
full time artist and writer marvel comics for the series daredevil Stanley and
artist and Bill Everett who'd created daredevil.
But Frank Miller is responsible for the dark and gritty hard edge that defined
the character.
He was able to explore New York's hell's kitchen firsthand,
accurately capture the essence of this area.
Since Miller was raised Irish Catholic,
he was also able to bring a lot of the internal struggles felts by daredevil
secret identity.
Matt Murdock,
who's religious beliefs stopped him from killing bad guys.
At that time.
Frank Miller had no aspirations to make original characters.
He was just thrilled to finally have a steady job working in the comic book
industry,
but it was clear that he had a unique artistic style and point of view.
He was constantly researching by reading comics from all over the world as he
thought a lot about how he could draw a seems to make the reader slow down and
really take their time on each page by giving them a visually interesting world.
He eventually created the character,
a lecturer during an interview.
He explains his motivations for creating the character,
stating daredevil had a lot of girlfriends,
but what about one who can kick his butt?
She became the first female character who was like the femme fatale of the old
film noir movies that he loved so much.
She was beautiful and she couldn't be trusted.
She was an assassin,
but I love Matthew mode or created a feeling of guilt.
Sorry to spoil it for those of who don't know,
but we do need to mention that Frank Miller made the decision.
This electra had to die for her crimes,
which he did at the hands of the villain bullseye.
Nothing like this.
Had ever been done in comics before,
especially with such a popular character before this,
most characters continued to live on forever,
even if they were villains.
It was dark and he showed that he was gearing the series towards adult readers.
This also really showed that frank had more about the storytelling.
Then he did the popularity Tangier fans.
They were upset by the death of a lecturer,
but Frank Miller put the story first.
Without worrying too much about the public opinion,
he was writing the story in a way that makes sense for the life and growth of
the characters.
He knew that Matt Murdock would never be able to settle down and have a happily
ever after life with a lecturer,
but they were too in love to ever leave each other,
so the only way for him to move on and be with someone else would be if a
lecturer died.
In 1983 he left marvel comics to work for DC.
He published a series called Ronin,
which was about a Samurai warrior.
Frank Miller had been inspired by French comics and Japanese and Nangeroni
borrowed from the styles that he discovered from both of these countries.
Specifically he credits lone wolf and cub by Kazuo we cars being his biggest
influence as well as the work of John Gorod who goes by the pen name Mobius.
Frank Miller began working together with an artist DC comics named Lynn Varley.
[inaudible] colored the drawings of Ronan.
They worked incredibly well together,
bouncing ideas off one another constantly.
She continued to do the inking on all of his future work.
They also fell in love and eventually he got married.
Sadly,
they divorced in 2005 d c loved his work so much so that they asked him to write
and draw a new Batman series.
At first he actually said no because he respected Batman as a character too much
after all.
It was the very first comic that had ever read since he knew that the character
meant just as much to millions of people around the world as it meant to him,
even though he was working full time in the comic book industry.
Those feelings of self doubt.
They were still there.
He was afraid that he wasn't good enough and that he might ruin Batman.
However,
he did keep the thought in the back of his mind.
For years,
the character of Batman had never aged.
He was permanently 29 years old and Robin was always his teenage sidekick.
He thought to himself,
I'll be damned if I'm older than Batman,
and it was at this point that he had a light bulb moments he imagined Batman in
his fifties he's older,
disillusions and Grizzles,
and for a man who's been dressing as a bat for so many years,
he's certainly going to have some psychological issues.
His story of Batman is far darker than any other version that did it ever come
before it.
And this comic was of course Batman,
the dark knight returns.
This became a huge success and did a specialty,
resonated with fans who had grown up with the character.
The movie adaptation of the dark night in 2008 became one of the most successful
superhero stories of all time and it's arguably the best board trial of that has
ever been made.
During an interview at the Cuban School of media,
Frank Miller was asked if he preferred daredevil or Batman.
He very quickly said Batman will always be number one in his heart because his
motivations behind his character,
a beautifully simple by man is trying to restore order to a world where there is
none.
While the joker is trying to create chaos because of that,
the story will stand the test of time
off to seeing success in the comic book industry,
Frank Mila,
to sign it that he wants it to move to a warmer climate.
So he left New York.
I moved to Los Angeles.
They had no intention of getting into the movie business,
but one day he got a phone call from a movie producer who wanted to work with
him on robocop two and three since he loved the first movie,
he agreed to work on the projects.
However,
the director was constantly changing Frank Miller's script during robocop two he
was on set every day one thing to be involved.
What about by robocop three?
He got so angry at the movie making process.
He decided to leave and never come back during an interview.
He said,
don't be the writer.
The director has got power,
the screenplay as a fire hydrants with a row of dogs waiting around the block
for it.
Miller played small cameo roles in Robocop two and three and z dies in both
films.
After getting these small screen credits,
he made cameos and some other movies too.
In 1994 both the Frank Miller and Stanley played themselves in a movie called
Juggler,
Weiner,
Vampire Odyssey.
There is even a scene.
West Stanley gets to kill Frank Miller,
so while they got to enjoy having fun and it can be horror film,
he's still begins to feel jaded and he didn't feel the same passion for his
career that he had back in New York.
He really wasn't doing what he actually loved.
He began to feel a lot of anx towards Los Angeles.
This is what inspired him to write sin city.
In 1991 he was inspired to make the story by a black and white comic called
Johnny Hazard by Frank Robbins and all of the film and Wa had watched as a kid.
He sold the idea to dark horse comics.
He decided to not hold back and just pour everything that he wanted into the
comic.
He's Eddie wanted it to have a tough guys,
beautiful women and vintage cars.
Since city was released in a series of graphic novels that are standalone
stories,
but they all exist in the same universe.
He continue to work on Sin City over the next few years because it was what he
truly enjoyed doing and he was totally satisfied with it being his one and only
project.
In 2003 a dead of all movie was released starring Ben Affleck.
Since the character rights belong to marvel,
frank mellow didn't have any creative input on the film.
Many fans felt that this movie did not capture the true essence of the dad of or
comics and they wouldn't get what they were looking for until Netflix created
the original series in 2015 starring Charlie Cox.
However,
in an interview in 2017 Miller said that he have not even bothered to watch the
Netflix series so he doesn't give any comments about what he personally thinks
about those adaptations.
Ironically,
even though he created the sin city comic after avenging,
his frustrations with Hollywood's and z really did not enjoy watching
adaptations of his work.
All of that would circle back in 2009 to five when he got the opportunity to
write and direct the sins that he with Robert Rodriguez.
At first Mila said no to the project because it sin city.
It was like his baby and he had seen what Hollywood had done to his work in the
past.
But Rodriguez,
he was a fan and he understood how important it was to portray the stories
accurately.
Rodriguez also gave Frank Mir like complete creative control so that he could
recreate his comics panel by panel and frame by frame.
They will act on showing the screen tests,
do several different actors and they were surprised and impressed by the work he
was able to attract a star studded Carstens.
Even Quentin Tarantino helps to direct the fight scenes in the movie during an
interview about Sin City,
he said that he was shocked at how much he enjoyed working together with the
actors.
He said,
I expected the worst and they got the best in the behind the scenes clips.
They're feeling seems to be mutual.
All of the actors were really happy that they could ask Frank Miller questions
is about the character's motivations as well as getting more depth about the
overall story.
Since then,
more or Frank Miller stories have been adapted to both the small and big
screens.
He continues to publish a new comics on a regular basis at 62 years old.
He is far from retiring anytime soon.
In 2018 Netflix audit,
a series called cast,
which is a dark reimagining of the King Arthur legend,
even though he's still making new material,
he has already reached legendary status and a lot of ways is images to find a
generation today.
His work has been on display in a number of art museums including the Norman
Rockwell museum and even the loof in Paris.
The work of the young man who was told that he wasn't good enough is now next to
some of the greatest artists in the world.
The Cherry on top of all of this success is that Frank Miller has made quite a
lot of money too.
He has an estimated net worth of $45 million.
He owns his fortune doing what he loved and doing it extremely well.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
If you're looking at something else to watch today,
why not check out my other channel called top tens.
We do top 10 videos.
We've got a bunch about comics and comic book artists and all of that stuff,
so go check out of that channel.
There's a link below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.